un astéroïde de la taille d'un bus va
frôler la Terre alors déjà le plus
important il ne présente aucun risque
pour notre planète dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi l'astéroïde va entrer en
contact avec l'atmosphère de la Terre
c'est le quatrième plus gros astéroïde
qui passe proche de la Terre et avoir
été enregistrée il est large d'environ
3,8 à 8,5 m les scientifiques ont
expliqué qu'un astéroïde de moins de 25
mètres de diamètre brûle lorsqu'il
rentre dans l'atmosphère l'astéroïde va
passer à 35000 km de la surface de la
Terre à une vitesse de 53000 km/h ce qui
représente une toute petite distance en
astronomie les scientifiques de la
nasale ont découvert samedi dernier et
l'ont nommé 2023 bu